he does not care
if he did care keystone would be going
biden and his administration ran on
buildback better
and that is from where i'm standing that
is that's crap
i think
his
new slogan should be
butchering booming business he's been
one disaster after another as far as i'm
concerned
can't stand him
we definitely need to change one year in
absolutely worthless
he's done nothing for us he's literally
pulled the rug out from under us and
killed our economy
because they close the keystone a lot of
small businesses and small communities
like this little mom and pops that are
kind of off the books like mine
we're suffering some of us are actually
closing
biden was it was huge i mean
he got no no love from this area i mean
there was going to be a lot of money
coming into here to help our schools
help our community i mean it was going
to be it was going to be a good deal
and he
trashed it
it took away a lot of the
potential for rentals for housing
and a lot of as you can see the business
on main street
a lot of the renters had to move away
because they no longer had jobs the city
actually actively looked for some
additional law enforcement because
there's going to be more people around
than normal
the school was actually concerned that
they needed to provide more
room for
possible students for people that
brought their families along so there's
a lot of preparation that went into it
and it kind of went down the drain when
it was canceled all these people that
invested to make our town better
and they're stuck holding the bay
because they still have to make the loan
payments on the improvements that they
they stuck their neck out to do it's
there's no common sense in making that
decision to shut down pipelines and then
turn around we have a problem with not
having enough
like do you really think honest to god
right now that old sleepy joe biden
gives one
wit
about an oil spill
no he doesn't
the helicopter that he rides air force
one the vehicles that he transports in i
bet none of them are electric
i bet he's not on green energy i think
we get skipped a lot they don't realize
that what we need and have to have for
our small towns is a lot different than
what the bigger towns have the options
of
it just seems like there's no no
no listening to the voices of small town
if we have an attitude that we don't
matter out here it's going to get worse
you